There are a lot of weird stories in the
Muslim sources. Stories that make you
wonder why in the name of common sense
would anyone ever write down something
like this. But I challenge you to find a
weirder, creepier, more disturbing story
than the tale of Muhammad's late night
desert rendevous with the men of Alz.
Since Raymon Ibrahim has already done
the research on Muhammad's romantic
encounter, we'll let Raymond break down
the details. This odd hadith which I'm
about to narrate appears in several
hadith collections, including the highly
esteemed Musnid of Nahul, founder of one
of Islam's four schools of laws or as
well as in many other wellrespected
Islamic texts, all of which are being
taught in Alazhar. So the scholars know
about this, but like so many other
issues the scholars hide from us, this
story hasn't worked its way to the
general
population until now. The hadith, which
is narrated by Abdullah bin Masoud, a
companion of the prophet and one of
Islam's most reliable and trustworthy
transmitters of a hadith goes as
follows. Brace
yourself. Abdullah begins by telling us
that Muhammad called on him to accompany
him on a trip into the desert. When they
reached a certain place and night had
fallen, Muhammad made a line in the
sand, most likely a circle, and told
Abdullah, quote, "Stay behind this line
and do not cross it, for if you do, you
will die." Muhammad drew a line in the
sand and warned his companion Abdullah
Ibn Masud not to cross it. Let's call
this line the Diddy line, as in Muhammad
didn't just cross that line, did he? We
could also call it the cuck line for
reasons that will soon be clear.
Muhammad then left his startled
companion and walked into the desert
night about the distance of a hurled
stone, says Abdullah. Before long, our
narrator saw a group of men. He does not
specify how many who quote appeared to
be al. He describes them as quote tall,
lean, and naked. So Abdullah ibn Masud
was behind the line, the cuck line. But
Muhammad crossed the diddy line, and he
was soon surrounded by a number of tall,
lean, naked men, the men of Alz.
Other Islamic sources say the Zut were a
black-skinned people and we'll get into
that later. After describing them,
Abdullah goes on, and here's a
problematic part to say, quote, "They
went to and began to ride the prophet of
Allah." They did what now? They went to
and began to ride the prophet of Allah.
Literally, that's what the Arabic says.
These tall, black naked men rode
Muhammad. The Arabic word yakabun, which
I will presently discuss, can also be
translated as mounted. And they did this
all night long, says Abdullah. These
tall, lean, black naked men mounted
Muhammad in the desert and rode him all
night long while his companion Abdullah
Iban Masoud watched from behind the
cockline during which time they would
also come and circle around and try to
reach him, but they were prevented
apparently from the line of protection
Muhammad had drawn in the sand for his
companion. Abdullah concludes his
narration, quote, I was extremely
terrified by them, so I sat down. With
the coming of dawn, they began to
depart. Then the prophet of Allah
returned slowly and in pain from that
which they did while riding him. These
tall, lean, black, naked men tried to
get to Iban Massud, but he was protected
by the deadline. He was terrified, so he
sat down. When dawn arrived, the tall,
lean, black naked men left, and Muhammad
came stumbling back to Iban Masoud
slowly because he was in pain from these
tall, lean, black naked men riding him
all night long. According to another
narration found in several Islamic
texts, including Akbar Mecca by Alah,
Muhammad complained to Abdullah that
quote, "They wounded me all night long."
At which point the prophet proceeds to
lay his head and fall asleep in
Abdullah's lap. Poor Muhammad was all
tuckered out from these tall, lean,
black naked men riding him all night
long. And he fell asleep with his head
resting on Iban Masud's
lap. Yes, Muhammad liked resting his
head on men's laps to fall asleep. Just
ask Deha al- Kalbi. But who were these
guys who mounted him and rode him all
night long? Turns out when they're
described as black, it doesn't mean
African. Who are these alz these naked
men who rode with Muhammad all night
long? According to Islam's written
records, they were a migrant people from
India or modern-day Pakistan. Described
in the sources as very tall, very
dark-skinned, very lean, strong and
hearty, and often used for labor
intensive work. Sounds like Muhammad was
using them for some labor inensive work.
So al- zut referred to people from India
or Pakistan. Do we know anything else
about these guys? In early Arabic
ethnographies and literary works, alz
are also depicted as being very sexual
and viral with very large penises. In
fact, according to one Arabic source by
Abiw, quote, "The penis of alz never
weakens," meaning their large fallaces
never go limp and are ever ready. The
men of Alz were known for being
extremely horny at all times. And
Muhammad wanted to meet with these men
at night in the desert and they mounted
him and rode him all night long while
Iben Massud watched from behind the
line. Raymond asked chat GBT about the
men of Alz. I then asked chat GBT to
give me a physical description of alz
based on early Arabic sources and it
said quote in literary and anecdotal
texts they are grouped together with
other southern or dark-kinned people all
of whom have the following traits sexual
potency prominent genitalia and
associations with physical strength and
verility. Why did Muhammad want to meet
these guys at night in the desert? And
what do the sources mean when they say
these guys were riding him all night
long? Now, let's talk about the Arabic
word translated as ride, as in
elut. Not only does it have the same
exact meaning in English, as in to ride
a horse, for example, but it carries the
same slang meaning as in copulating with
a woman. In fact, several Islamic
sources use it literally to mean sex. So
when it says they rode him all night
long, the word rode can either mean they
rode him like a horse or it can mean
they had sex with
him. What do you think it means in this
context? It's also interesting to note
that when Alz began circling and trying
to reach our terrified narrator
Abdullah, his first instinct was to sit
down. Was he trying to hide and protect
that one part of his body which these
naked men were apparently trying to
access, that is his bottom, by sitting
down? Well, he saw what they were doing
to poor Muhammad's junk in the trunk.
So, we can't blame him for sitting down
and protecting his badonadon from the
booty bandits of
Alz. All right, now that we know the
details, Raymond puts it all together.
Muhammad took his close companion
Abdullah into the desert at night. He
warned him to wait behind a line and
went off at a distance, apparently for a
pre-planned rendevu. Before long,
Abdullah saw several naked men from the
people of Elzut appear, described in the
sources as tall, lean, veriral, and with
large penises. Why was Muhammad meeting
these guys at night in the desert after
crossing the diddy line? These men then
took turns riding or mounting the
prophet all night long. They also tried
to reach him, but Abdullah immediately
sat down. Apparently to protect that one
part of his body they were trying to
access. Iban Massud apparently did a
better job protecting his bubble pop
than Muhammad did. As the sun rose,
these naked men began to depart. Even as
Muhammad returned in pain, limping
towards Abdullah and saying how alut had
injured him. He then lays in his
companion's lap and falls asleep.
Nothing suspicious here. So, this is
what I would consider the weirdest,
creepiest, most disturbing story in the
Muslim sources. And that's saying a lot.
But maybe I'm wrong. Maybe I'm missing
something. Let me ask all our Muslim
friends what this means. Why did
Muhammad head out into the desert in the
middle of the night to meet with a bunch
of Indian or Pakistani men? men who are
known for their strong sexual
appetites. Why did he bring his
companion Abdullah ibn Masud and make
him stand behind the diddy
line? Did Muhammad like it when one of
his
companions
watched? What do your sources mean when
they say that these tall, lean, black
naked men mounted Muhammad and rode him
all night long? When the men of Alz
approached the diddy line or the cuck
line, why did Iban Masoud sit down to
protect the jiggle twins, his wiggle
bags, his rump rockets? And why did
Muhammad return to Iban Masoud in pain,
totally worn out from having his bounce
house bounced on all night and pass out
on his companion's lap?
Let me know in the comments section. If
you'd like to watch Raymond Ibrahim's
full video, the link is in the
description box. Be sure to check out
his channel as well. As you can see,
he's got a lot of good material.
[Music]